It's easy to be calm and
mindful when you're in a cave.
But how do you do it in the
world and how do you do it
under extreme duress?
That's what reveals character.
As a kid I was really sort of
naturally insecure
until I discovered drugs and
alcohol and that was like the
miracle salve that solved
every problem that up to
that point I didn't know that I
had.
I was a pretty broken guy.
It was a pretty dire
dark scenario.
I woke up one day hung over and
decided I'm finally ready to do
something about this.
And went off to rehab.
And I was able to actually grab
onto that rope and
start doing that interior work.
That was my first introduction
to meditation.
I had this moment walking up
these steps late one night
where I had to pause and I had
tightness in my chest and sweat
on my brow and really fear in
my heart that I was on the
precipice of a very serious
heart issue and it scared me.
And that began the process of
me once again reconfiguring
my life.
I became amazed at how
resilient the human body is
because for so many years I
had beaten myself up with drugs
and alcohol and fast food and
workaholism and you name it.
And I realized that if my body
could bounce back this quickly
from all the terrible
treatment that I've given it
for most of my life like what
is it really capable of?
That's what introduced me to
Ultra Man.
For people that don't know it's
a double Iron Man distance
triathlon.
Three hundred twenty miles that
over a three day period
circumnavigates the entire Big
Island of Hawaii.
It's insane.
It's very easy to get freaked
out and think oh my gosh I
can't do this.
Who am I kidding or this is too
painful I want to just stop.
So in a race like Ultra Man
it's crucial to
be able to anchor yourself in
the present moment.
You have to be able to let go
of what just happened and what
is in your near future and
focus on what is happening
right now. And the more you can
do that then all of that
fear kind of evaporates.
Your thinking mind is that
pesky guy on your shoulder he's
trying to talk you out of
everything.
And so the trick becomes
learning how to tap into
a higher state of awareness
so that you can be mindful and
you can be present.
And that's the place you want
to be in as an athlete because
that's when you're completely
centered and focused.
And I will say in all honesty
that Headspace has been really
great for helping me have
a consistent approach to my
practice because it is right
on my phone and I put it down
in the dock at the bottom.
It's a constant reminder and
it's so easily accessible.
To be able to do it wherever
you find yourself
for somebody who's beginning to
meditate five minutes might
seem like an eternity.
And that's what I experienced
during this training like I can
get to a place where a seven
hour ride didn't feel like that
long.
And that's really a
mental practice.
Yes there is physical
discomfort and the training is
athletic and physical.
But truly a race like Ultra Man
all comes down to your mental
emotional and spiritual state
and that is really the defining
characteristic that would
define any any champion in
that regard.